very big news a connecticut has passed
the bill to change from an electoral
vote system to a popular vote system for
assigning their electoral votes in
presidential elections and we were just
talking about the electoral vote versus
popular vote for president issue last
week Donald Trump said he would prefer a
popular vote for president we had a live
caller asked about it and last week I
mentioned that for constitutional and
sort of practical reasons it would be
much more pragmatic to pursue the npv I
see the national popular vote interstate
compact rather than changing our
constitution to abolish the Electoral
College if we wanted to do that you'd
need a constitutional amendment
introduced in Congress you need a 2/3
yes vote in the House and Senate to send
it to the states and then 3/4 of the
state legislatures or state conventions
would need to ratify it which is a very
very uphill battle because even if Trump
is silly enough to think that the
national popular vote would help
Republicans at the state level you do
have Republican operatives who are aware
that the Electoral College has given two
wins to Republicans even when they lost
the popular vote in the last five
elections so the alternative is for
individual states to decide that
regardless of how their state votes they
will assign their electoral votes to
whoever wins the national popular vote
and the idea the math of it is once you
get enough states to agree to this such
that in total they have 270 electoral
votes the number needed to win you have
a de facto national popular vote you
don't need a constitutional amendment so
in Connecticut the state Senate voted in
favor of doing exactly that it already
has passed the House the Democratic
Governor Dannel Malloy is expected to
sign it and that would make Connecticut
the 11th state plus Washington DC to
adopt this system and that means that
the npv I see will be up to 172
electoral votes in total this means
they're about 2/3 of the way to the 270
total that they need for this to become
a reality so big progress but this is
going to be a significant challenge I
know that it was laughed away years ago
is it's going to get no traction I know
that it's two-thirds of the way there
but the
problem is that now you're going to need
some red or purple states to do this
right now it's basically all blue states
it's California Washington State Hawaii
Maryland Massachusetts New Jersey New
York Rhode Island Vermont and Washington
DC plus most recently Connecticut you
now are going to need either a purple
state which is unlikely to want to do it
or a red state to say we're gonna jump
on board there is a reason that red
states might want to get involved which
is that because of the system we have
the Electoral College candidates rarely
go to low population red states unless
they're some of those early primary
states in which case it matters right
but the reliably red states like Utah
the Dakotas Wyoming they're effectively
completely ignored during presidential
elections so they might want to join up
merely because they don't like how the
Electoral College is affecting them but
those aren't high population states and
thus they're only going to very very
slowly interest towards the 270 votes
that are needed before this becomes a
reality so I think that this is
fantastic but there's still a lot that
needs to happen before this becomes a
thing yeah reason for concern it's only
blue states that have done this so far
right so if you have a situation where
the scenarios that we've seen the past
few election cycles reverse and a
Republican wins the popular vote but a
Democrat wins the electoral college yes
that's not gonna be enough
I think the Democrat would have to win
both the popular vote and the electoral
college to assume the presidency oh I
think you could play putting yourself at
a disadvantage there and I understand
this is for a greater purpose it's for
strengthening our democracy more so than
just helping one party or another you're
going to get both blue states and red
states on board yeah I think you're
right even if it were possible for this
to happen with only blue states it would
be from a PR perspective complicated and
it can't happen right and and I think
that the red states are probably more
likely to be interested in this than the
purple states and I do want to mention
something else
remember how I've been harping on the
importance of the 2020 census the census
also would affect this because census
data is used to adjust the number of
electoral votes per state so you could
end up with
situation where you get enough states
joining the NPV I see to get say 271
electoral votes you do the census and
then because of population shifts those
states that used to have 271 electoral
votes end up getting shifted to only to
68 or to 69 and then you lose the NPV I
see unless you add another state that
that could happen which is why it is
really really really important that the
census be fully funded and done
correctly I know it's not a sexy issue I
know every time I talk about it
some people glaze over but there are so
many ways in which this matters that
we've got to take it really really
seriously today's program is made
possible in part by futur futur is a
social forecasting game where you
compete with other players to predict
the future and it's built on the
principles of what's called a prediction
market a scientifically proven way of
using the wisdom of the crowd to create
more accurate predictions about future
events prediction markets have been
shown to work much better than other
forecasting methods like polling or
expert analysis in many cases and futur
has actually taken the concept and
turned it into a fun easy to use social
game you open up the futur app and
you'll see a whole range of forecasts
covering topics across the board from
politics to sports and everything in
between you can check out my predictions
and follow me to get updates on my
profile which is linked to in the
description if you're watching this on
YouTube the tour is a great tool to find
out more about the world improve your
forecasting ability show off your
prediction skills to friends and even
better when you make predictions on
futur you're helping to create more
accurate forecasts for everybody their
mission of creating better predictions
is great and actually going in there and
seeing how well you can do at predicting
the future can be kind of addicting go
to futur com sign up and start making
forecast it's free and it's available on
both Android and iOS as well as on web
browsers and that's f you t you you are
calm